Sofia this is what your eight here eight
years yep more it's all against 9th or
16 we're planning and it's going to be
another big fest thousand submissions
last year but double that this year we
have already started a call for entries
on a soft launch now we have a official
launch happening this monday so it takes
wishes from everywhere last year we had
submissions from about 37 countries
hoping to duplicate that again this year
okay now from when you first started
eight years ago to now how's the
technology changed and how's the quality
changed other submissions I'm sure it's
got to be just totally different we had
I mean you know from our first year in
2005 which we showed we had 23
submissions that we showed about twenty
three films you know back then we had
submissions in VHS you know and
now
smart phones and submitting them
the technology level is up there thing
is with these technology improvements
a lot of the films that we get quality
is the bars raised level of visually we
have an amazing aesthetically looking
films the problem is since you have the
technologies is sped up and these things
look better yet as a programmer it is a
festive reviewer and it had your sharp
eye because the story lines is what
separates what's good and what's just
looks good it's kind of like a I don't
know a Ferrari and a car that looks like
a Ferrari but there's an evident you
know so you got to take a get to look
twice as hard now as a program where it
is the best director because the bars
been rickys because anyone can make a
short film now there's HD cams right now
are more prevalent and they're more
cost-effective so
makes our job that much tougher
what would you recommend to a filmmaker
who's won a festival any festival what
should they do after they win because I
think so many people think that they can
just rest on that sort of wave and then
it dies down and how do you keep that
momentum going that's a really really
good question because it's I've seen
just this past year we have a winner
michael began is basically the UK you
know I haven't seen somebody this
tenacious in a very long time you know
ok I want best overall knowledge that
you could just do that look this guy you
know he's very active on Twitter I've
seen him personally make connections I
love the film it was like a game or not
to world
okies reached out the filmmakers that
are you know already established in
making co10
check out my movie what Holly shorts
here's a link to my video file after the
festival you got in touch with our jury
our judges our sponsors and you saying
look around I'm available on the winner
let me know if I can be of assistance
follow up I guess that's the key you got
to follow up with the people that you
met at the festival's those business
cards that you've got instead of just
liquids in your wallet try to engage the
people we try to take it to the next
level I think Mike's done a really good
job doing that yeah I can't you can't
regress some of the rollers you got to
follow up you got to do the due
diligence send out your press release
afterwards I'm your festival win do
collaborations that's the thing that's
cool about Molly shorts is can't tell
you how many others fishes that we
receive that are collaborations from
years past sometimes when filmmakers a
director
director met another producer or writer
and now they worked on a project to
guess what they submitted it again
molecules in other festivals and that's
that's really unique you know it's
really cool um something that we do as
well as we take a lot of our top winners
in alumni and judges I just engages the
back of the festival keeps them on the
pulse of the independent
like we have Auto reoccurring filmmakers
because it may be exceptional short
films like Cat Cora was exploited that
indie film space she's another fine
Holly she's had on a brief little
project
and she contacts us sometime since
they're going to film screening you got
something going on so in summary
follow-up engaging in the best directors
that you've met the people that you've
met and I'm just continuing that contact
and growing your network that's that's a
critical
um someone makes a film a feature or
short what should they said is their
goal for the amount of festivals they
should submit to I'm sure it's dependent
on their budget but what's realistic I'm
you don't want to be spreading your
energy too thin but at the same time you
don't want to limit yourself and just
say I'm only going for Sunday answer
Seattle and and nothing else not some of
the smaller ones yeah things like you
said it depends on the film that depends
on your budget depend them you know what
your goal is as well on a feature level
right if your goal is distribution on a
domestic distribution in foreign you
know what do you want what a pay TV deal
you want a
theatrical you want a VOD what's your
goal what's the integral for the project
for the short what's your goal to do you
want as much exposure as possible do you
want Kennedy what if cultivate you fan
basing what do you want to reach first
you set your goal then you decide on
what's the upper echelon fests that you
want to get in you know the top five in
the country you know just domestically
we're speaking and then what are the top
ones internationally if you want to get
into you want to feel too and then the
plan b's the sub ones and those
territories you know like if it's in los
angeles is it the Los Angeles Film
Festival okay if I don't get in then
mr. second be level festival that's in
la that still prominent but that's not
on the LA press level I member ish an
independent feature film that I worked
with ten years back they really wanted
to get into Sundance didn't get
they got it they work they wanted to
make it like a big premiere you might
think we got it in edinboro she's huge
overseas and use that as their you know
their big premiere they want
Peyton so again it just depends on what
your goals are for the film do you want
to try to get in it also is it you know
do you want to get into a film market
like a Berlin you know some some of the
major festival of markets associated
with them so that maybe falls into your
consideration now here's the thing is
you know now a lot of these festivals
accept online screeners so it seems a
filmmaker a lot of money I have a film
now I want to put it out to 20 of the
top film festivals right five years ago
I would have to put fedex fedex my mail
are out now I can just go online they
accept online screeners I you know
without a box is an online system I just
see myself with thousands of dollars you
know that's
exciting to filmmaker another and
there's a lot of other services that are
coming up that are a lot of festivals
are accepting online readers to that's
that's critical you know and we're doing
in the independent film world you know a
couple thousand